[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur arte
france pour un nouveau numéro du débrief
du dock ensemble on va s'intéresser 7
faux documentaire intitulé mig sukhoï lé
secret des avions de combat russes et
pour en parler je ne suis pas seule elle
nous sommes avec le général patrick
charest bonjour monsieur charest ou
plutôt mon général d'ailleurs comment
dois je vous appeler oui vous pouvez
m'appeler général patrick sharks
eh bien écoutez mon général avant de
rentrer dans le vif du sujet je voulais
tout simplement vous présentez un aux
téléspectateurs puisque vous aviez une
grande carrière
un militaire vous êtes ancien pilote de
chasse vous avez commandé la base
aérienne de djibouti est tenu des postes
en état major au commandement de la
défense aérienne et dans les forces
aériennes
j'ai dit vous avez été général de corps
aérien vous avez surtout tenu le poste
de commandant des forces aériennes
stratégiques en charge la composante
aérienne air de la dissuasion nucléaire
est-ce que j'ai tout dit oui oui oui
vous avez tout dit pour la carrière
militaire aujourd'hui il s'avère je suis
aussi président de les pilotes de chasse
est donc ce que ce documentaire
évidemment m'a beaucoup touché vous
faites bien de dire j'avais donc oublié
quelque chose vous parler de ce
documentaire que l'on a vu bien sûr
première question qu'avez vous pensé de
ce documentaire est ce que vous
connaissez bien les appareils russes
ah oui oui pourquoi pas parce que
pendant ces trente six années de
carrière et notamment les douze années
dans l'escadron de chasse l'ennemi entre
guillemets c'était rappelez vous débutez
le bloc est ouest et est la
confrontation est l'ennemi était le
russe et donc ses avions là je les ai
évidemment combattue par aux exercices
et c'est très intéressant parce que je
me retrouve un peu dans ces quelques
années parce que vous avez peut-être
noter quand même tous ses avions là ont
quand même 40 ans d'existence
donc on parle quand même de chasse
soviétique ou chasse russes dans la
transition à la fin du bloc mais on
parle quand même
d'une génération à ses anciennes
d'ailleurs un des pilotes le dit on est
bien dans la deuxième génération
d'avions de chasse aujourd'hui vous
savez on est dans la 4ème ou 5ème
génération avant de parler justement de
ces appareils de ses avions que vous
vous connaissez bien
j'aimerais qu'on s'intéresse aux pilotes
dans ce documentaire on entend un pilote
russe parler de de son expérience de sa
passion je vous propose de regarder un
extrait ensemble et puis on débrief
juste après j'ai grandi à côté de la
base aérienne
tous les vols qui ont lieu depuis le
centre aérien de tête ce que se sont dit
oui depuis mon enfance je rêvais de
devenir pilote et votre code de chasse
pour effectuer les manoeuvres que seuls
les avions de chasse avec mon rêve s'est
réalisé
je pilote un mig 29 je crois que cet
appareil est parmi les meilleurs au
monde
il offre de nombreuses possibilités aux
pilotes est devenu pilote de cet
appareil
je suis absolument ravi alors vous
l'avez entendu un mon général dans cet
extrait on entend le pilote parler de de
sa passion de son rêve de devenir pilote
vous êtes d'accord avec ce qu'il dit
c'est c'est une véritable vocation que
de devenir pilote
oui vous savez que quand on est jeune on
est toujours tirée vers vers le ouvert
l'espace vert l'avion de chasse on pense
à guillemets on pense bien sûr aux héros
et aux as de la grande guerre et puis de
la seconde guerre mondiale et puis le
vietnam et puis on a quand même des
références comme ça et quand on est
jeune il faut avoir quelque chose qui
vous fait briller dans les yeux il vous
faut tourner vers un un projet d'avenir
et cette vocation là vous l'avez
notamment en regardant en l'air et en
regardant ce qui s'y passe et donc je
comprends tout à fait ce pilote de
chasse d'ailleurs pour l'avoir aussi
vécu quand vous êtes dans
l'environnement d'une base aérienne
quand vous entendez ces avions qui
décollent avec la postcombustion qui
passe en très basse altitude
vous les regardez en disant c'est le
rêve d'icare ses volets c'est
s'affranchir de cette troisième
dimension est là pour le coup vous rêvez
et donc ce métier quand même pas facile
il faut l'avouer avec pas mal de
difficultés à la fois physique pression
et puis surtout la technologie
il faut savoir combattre tout ça et ça
vous le faites à travers votre foi votre
votre vocation est ce qui vous fait
tirer vers le haut et accepté entre 10
mai entre guillemets ses difficultés du
moment
alors c'est un métier qui a aussi était
sublimée au cinéma on pense au film top
gun mais forcément la réalité est bien
est bien différente on apprend dans le
documentaire que l'on a que l'on a vu
qu' il faut quatre ans de services pour
maîtriser à peu près tout les l'émission
et devenir opérationnels devenir pilote
vous l'avez dit c'est un métier à très
difficile quelles sont les qualités
selon vous pour pour devenir un bon
pilote et bien pour être un bon pilote
déjà il va falloir passer deux tests qui
sont fondamentaux pour pouvoir de c'est
à dire le test médical et allah vous
pouvez rien si vous êtes daltoniens si
votre colonne vertébrale et pas droite
pour le siège éjectable
vous serez naturellement éliminé et
saint vous n'y pouvez rien c c'est
physique céline et et puis ensuite il va
falloir passer ces tests
psychotechniques qui montrent que dans
la troisième dimension
vous réagissez vous n'êtes pas malade et
vous êtes capable de prendre un peu tout
ce qui touche aux côtés physiologique et
un peu médical pour être un bon pilote
d'abord la condition physique c'est pour
çà dire qu'on fait beaucoup de sport
fait beaucoup de 2,2 de course à pied
pour le coeur pour pouvoir soutenir ces
facteurs de charge est aussi aujourd'hui
avec c'est à dire électrique on prend
quand même l'une objets coin donc on
pèse 9 fois son corps vous imaginez le
sens qu'ils quittent le cerveau et donc
il faut il faut résister ensuite il faut
avoir un peu cette vision du court terme
c'est à dire je réagis en fonction de ce
qui se passe autour de moi j'ai cette
vision dans la 3d dans les trois
dimensions
je sais où vient la menace je sais je la
vois et donc pour ça j'ai évidemment
besoin d'une bonne vision et à la fois
aujourd'hui je suis capable de gérer
tous mes capteurs dans mon avion c'est
parce que j'ai fait une différence entre
par exemple un mig 29 qu'on aperçoit un
peu et aujourd'hui un rafale l'intérieur
de l'avion est complet
différents dans ce documentaire un mig
et soukhoï les secrets des avions de
combat russes on s'intéresse davantage à
la flotte à la flotte russe est ce que
vous la connaissez 7,7 l'autre us vous
avez dit que vous l'avez entre
guillemets combattu lors d'exercices que
lors de votre carrière qu'est ce que
vous en pensez aujourd'hui de cette
flotte russe
pour vous donner un exemple concret
quand j'étais commandant l'escadron sur
mirage 2000 j'ai fait une opération avec
les allemands et c'était juste à la
chute du mur et les allemands en gros de
l'ouest avait pris un escadron de mig 29
de l'est avaient mis leurs pilotes
entraîné pour justement que les membres
de l'otan puissent s'entraîner contre le
mig-29 et donc j'ai vraiment entre
guillemets fait du combat bien sûr
d'exercice mais du combat aérien avec le
mig-29 c'est un avion pour parler du mig
29 et de l'avion russe en général qui
pousse beaucoup
pourquoi vous savez que pour qu'un avion
de chasse pouces c'est la température à
la sortie de tuyères qui va pousser et
nous avions occidentaux on est du genre
800 degrés le russe va jusqu'à 1000
degrés c'est dire combien le moteur
russe en règle générale est très
puissant et qu'est ce que ça change mon
général justement que que la température
soit plus élevé vous avez plus de
puissance et donc dans les virages
serrés par exemple vous tournez plus
serrée dans un combat tournoyant vous
monter plus haut si vous mettez le néo
dans votre avion puisque votre moteur
plus pousse pousse plus et puis vous
n'allez pas plus vite parce que nous
avions sont aussi rapides les plus
rapides font jour mc2 comme comme nous
comme les occidentaux mais cette
puissance là elle vous permet dans les
évolutions et la manoeuvre de prendre
l'aventage sur l'autre et nous ont fait
800 degrés eux et ils formulent degrés
mais l'inconvénient et on l'a vu sur le
mig-29 concept quand on s'est entraîné
avec eux c'est que les matériaux ne
résiste pas aussi bien 1000 degrés et
donc par exemple un pilote de chasse
russes de mig-29 ne peut brancher sa
post combustion que deux minutes par vol
c'est c'est une limitation
extraordinaire quand on sait que sur le
rafale mirage 2000 lemay
on en a besoin en combat au décollage le
mig-29 est quand même assez limité à
cause de cette température donc des
moteurs puissants mais mais mais une
petite limitation dans l'emploi vous
parler bien sûr de la différence entre
entre ces appareils on connaît les
célèbres avions de chasse à travers le
monde le raptor américain le sukhoï
russe vous parlez du rafale en france
est ce qui vous est arrivé à votre
carrière de piloter des avions étrangers
et quel regard vous portez justement sur
les flottes étrangères
moi j'ai eu l'occasion bien sûr puisque
on s'entraîne très régulièrement voire
aux barres en permanence avec l'otan et
donc j'ai fait un tour de f-16 en
biplace mais j'ai jamais eu l'occasion
de rencontrer afin de monter dans un
avion russe
mais vous savez que nous français on a
une vraie particularité vis-à-vis du
russe c'est l'expérience du normandie
niemen et on a un contact avec les
escadrons de chasse russes un nom ils
viennent chez nous un nom revient chez
eux on a une relation nous français très
particulière dans le domaine de pilote
de chasse 1 de l'aviation de chasse avec
cette histoire du normandie niémen vous
savez ces pilotes français qui sont
allés parce que l'impulsion du général
de gaulle faire la seconde guerre
mondiale à côté des russes au début
c'était l'escadron normandie ils se sont
tellement bien débrouillé avec des
victoires aériennes a soutenu les russes
que les russes leur en donner le
qualificatif niemen dans la fameuse
bataille d'une yémen et donc ces
échanges là on les a faits en face à
face et vous savez comme moi que le
russe en général ne parle pas beaucoup
ne donne pas beaucoup d'informations sur
ces sur ses capacités sur ces avions
pour ça que c'est un set cette vidéo
c'est cette reportage est très
intéressant même encore une fois si on
parle d'avions qui ont 40 ans elle est
importante cette collaboration entre les
aviateurs français et russes cette
collaboration elle peut être important
de syrte où se retrouvent sur le maître
théâtre
si dans la coalition ont fait face à un
ennemi on sait en gros comment on
travaille même si évidemment ont tout à
fait leur norme par exemple n'a vu qu'un
un avion de chasse russes ces
indicateurs seront km et en kilomètres
heure alors que nous on est en pied et
en eux c'est le côté un peu anglo saxons
donc quand vous avez la description de
ses avions vous avez vu les plafonds 100
km 10000km l'ami km et la vitesse étant
km heure mais cette importance de se
connaître et officiellement c'est pour
une action commune plus tard évidemment
aujourd'hui compte tenu du contexte et
tournait plutôt en train de regarder le
russe comme étant de l'autre côté de la
barrière
mais mais entre pilotes de chasse dans
des rencontres dans des échanges
on est dans une famille dans une même
famille quoi j'ai envie de dire c'est
comme si on parlait de pêcheurs le
pêcheur quelle que soit sa nationalité
sa passion c'est la paix choix eh bien
j'ai envie de dire la passion du pilote
de chasse et de parler et de raconter
ses expériences bien sûr on paraît
justement ensemble de ces différences à
entre entre les appareils parmi les
avions de combat qui existe aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il y en aurait un plus
performant qu'un autre et où un homme
qui vous impressionne plus
particulièrement encore une fois la
grande difficulté parce que c'est que
les russes ne communique pas sur leurs
avions sur leurs capacités mais on sait
qu'aujourd'hui le sukhoï 57 et le futur
qui arrive le futur 1041 qui arrivent
sont les deux futurs avions de cinquième
génération et c'est d'ailleurs il
l'appelle comme cela et donc on est et
le peu de choses près équivalent au f-35
au f-22 et le rafale et de quatrième
génération plus là on parle de cinquième
génération
on parle beaucoup donc du coup le
système de systèmes d'intégration
d'intelligence artificielle
moyennant quoi si on veut regarder un
peu concrètement sur le terrain
le rafale a fait vraiment ses preuves
dans tous les derniers théâtres
d'opération mais pour vous dire que les
avions qui peuvent impressionner
aujourd'hui sont effectivement peut-être
ses avions russes si on les connaissait
un peu mieux
je note au passage que les chinois sont
aussi en train de après à force de
regarder de copier aussi sont aussi en
train de créer des avions qui sont de
très bonnes technologies
la problème c'est comment on n'a pas
d'informations on peut pas comparer
vraiment mais le f-35 évidemment du côté
occidental fait
fait un peu rêver et le futur skaff
européen d'assaut vous savez que les
allemands et tous vers bus on construit
quelque chose pour 2035 2040 qui semble
être extraordinaire est à la hauteur
voire légèrement supérieurs à ceux là
général charest vous restez avec nous on
va continuer bien sûr à débriefer
ensemble de ce documentaire mitsouko et
les secrets des avions de combat russes
ont fait une petite pause et on se
retrouve juste après un tri site
nous sommes de retour dans ce débris du
doc sur arte france consacrée aux
documentaires milk sukhoï les secrets
des avions de combat russes nous sommes
toujours en compagnie du général
charest qs merci général ça risque
d'être une nouvelle fois avec nous
aujourd'hui on parle depuis tout à
l'heure un bien sur deux de ses avions
de chasse que vous connaissez a
parfaitement des avions de chasse qui
sont aujourd'hui équipées des toutes
dernières technologies
qu'est-ce qui vous interpelle le plus en
matière de nouvelles technologies dans
les avions qu'on peut on peut voir
aujourd'hui sur sur la planète
ce qui est intéressant évidemment et
l'avion de chasse pour ça est très
technologique
comparé aux autres armées et évidemment
c'est la recherche et l'innovation dans
ce domaine technologique et comment tout
cela intervient ou se met en place au
sein de la ville en chasse vous savez le
pilote
aujourd'hui par exemple de rafales sur
ses dix doigts il a 37 commandes
différentes avec des interrupteurs en
fonction bref de tous et et il va
commander son radar sa roulette de
noeuds pour ou son phare de
ravitaillement bref ce qui m'intéresse
vraiment aujourd'hui c'est qui
m'interpelle un peu c'est comment
l'intelligence artificielle par exemple
va arriver
le pilote en gros la limitation de cet
avion de chasse sera en gros la
perception du pilote donc ce qui
m'interpelle c'est ce que toutes ces
remarques et tous ces dossiers sur faut
t'il un pilote demain dans la glande
combat tellement cette manoeuvre
tellement cet outil cette capacité et
technologique
évidemment j'ai ma réponse est je pense
que le pilote à un moment ou un autre et
indispensable au moins pour la dissuader
la décision en hi media en fonction de
la situation qui évolue mais le côté
technologique le côté aussi système de
systèmes et à dire que votre avion va
attraper des capteurs de l'espace
bien sûr les satellites les radars les
autres avions les drones et en gros
l'avion de chasse ne sera qu'un élément
de tout un système dans lequel il est
intégré et il va communiquer avec tout
ce système est donc ça c'est quelque
chose
vous imaginez qui est bien loin du
pilote qui était la première guerre
mondiale dans son biplan
dans son triplan ou là c'était la
qualité de son avion dans sa qualité
aéronautique de vol et dans sa capacité
lui pilote à être un as pas ce qu'il
perçoit les choses là à la rigueur un
bon pilote sera aussi celui qui est
capable de percevoir tout son
environnement technologique réseau vous
l'avez compris et donc ça c'est quelque
chose qui fait évoluer petit à petit la
fonction du pilote de chasse est
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs en parle beaucoup
d'un officier système d'armes par
exemple navigateur de l'époque derrière
dans un biplace on l'appelait navigateur
aujourd'hui on l'appelle systèmes
d'armes officier système d'armes
c'est pour vous dire la complexité de
ces nouvelles machines alors des
machines justement de plus en plus
performantes équipées des toutes
dernières technologies on imagine
forcément que l'entretien est quelque
chose d'extrêmement important pour pour
c'est pour cette toute nouvelle machine
je vous propose justement de regarder un
extrait de ce documentaire intitulé
toujours milk sukhoï les secrets et des
avions de combat russes
justement qui parle d entretien des
avions on le regarde ensemble et on en
parle juste après
l'inspection pré-vol de l'aviation
tactique menée en russie est bien
différente des standards en vigueur dans
les forces armées aériennes de nombreux
pays membres de l'otan ou les avions de
combat partent en vol après une simple
inspection des principaux organes
seulement
[Musique]
les ingénieurs et les mécaniciens russes
inspectent avec rigueur toutes les
parties et les systèmes de l'avion avant
chaque vol au moindre doute
le vol est annulé
[Musique]
selon la tradition la dernière touche de
l'inspection pré vol et le lustrage du
lampadaire
c'est ainsi que les pilotes et les
mécaniciens appelle la perrière de la
cabine de pilotage
alors mon général on entend dans cet
extrait au début que l'inspection des
appareils avant les vols est parfois
différente en russie de ce que l'on peut
connaître dans l'est dans les pays de
l'otan qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous
en dites oui c'est très intéressant
parce que ces deux conceptions
différentes c'est à dire que pour l'otan
et pour nous français quand l'avion de
chasse se pose et qu'il a fini sa
mission
c'est à ce moment là que l'on fait
toutes les vérifications que l'on fait
le plein de carburant que l'on passe les
éléments de mesure électronique et tout
pour savoir si le système est intègre
pour que le lendemain à tout moment
pendant la nuit soit prêt à décoller et
que le lendemain on n'est plus qu'à
vérifier les comme comme le dit le
reportage les éléments essentiels
mais dans la nuit on estime qu'il n'y a
pas grand-chose qui a bougé donc cette
conception est elle est intéressante
parce qu'elle est différente nous une
fois que la mission réaliser l'avion
doit être prêt a redécollé à tout moment
s'il ya besoin et notamment pendant la
nuit la nuit ça c'est je pense que c'est
l'expérience un peu de la guerre froide
et et cette tension permanente qui ont
fait évoluer un peu les choses
je note au passage et c'est là vous
l'avez vu dans ces images que quand même
on parle vous avez les moyens sont assez
rustique
le mécanicien quand on voit la boîte
qu'il a devant lui aujourd'hui dans tous
les avions modernes vous brancher une
pomme une prise électrique avec bordeaux
votre ordinateur qui va tester tous les
éléments et qui va vous dire celui qui
est en panne et je note enfin pour
conclure c'est l'importance d'avoir une
visière propre là pour nous le cockpit
parce que c'est à travers le cockpit que
voit le pilote et ça ça doit être nickel
alors on imagine bien sûr que ces
entretiens ont un coût mais ce qui a un
coût aussi c'est les avions en eux mêmes
on en parlait tout à l'heure du rafale
un considérée comme le fleuron
de l'armée de l'air en france on sait
aussi qu'il est compliqué de vendre des
rafale à des puissances étrangères
pourquoi justement est ce que c'est si
compliqué aujourd'hui de vendre des
rafale et pourquoi le marché toujours
dominé notamment par les américains et
par les russes d'abord on peut pas dire
aujourd'hui qu'ils aient des difficultés
puisque la fin alors là vendu vous
l'avez vu à beaucoup de pays la preuve
c'est que on est en train de développer
les cadences de production de rafale
pour la grèce le qatar l'egypte tous ces
pays qui ont acheté du rafale donc j'ai
envie de dire on est à la taille de
notre pays quand même et notre industrie
on peut pas du tout se permettre de
faire comme l'américain à vendre à ce
niveau si important mais je pense que
peut-être au départ on a parlé de coup
on a parlé de ce système peut être un
peu occidental où il ya un élément qui a
été primordial dans la réussite du
rafale c'est ce qu'on appelle le
combattent province c'est à dire que
nous l'avons utilisé sur tous les champs
d'opérations en afghanistan en libye
aujourd'hui en irak en syrie aura
utilisé au mali et en gros on a montré
et les opérationnels les militaires les
pilotes ont montré au monde ou à ceux
qui étaient intéressés des écrans des
photos des résultats opérationnels de
l'action du rafale et donc ça ça a été
peut-être à mon avis l'élément qui a
fait que les autres nations intéressées
ont acheté du rafale et le deuxième
élément c'est peut-être qu'à un moment
ou un autre on se dit peut-être qu'il ne
faut pas être que tributaire de
l'américain et que peut-être avoir
d'autres fournisseurs et d'avoir une
flotte qui puisse dépendre d'autres pays
quand je n'ai pas ma propre aéronautique
bien sûr nationale eh bien je suis moins
tributaire de l'américain sur un plan
extérieur la france possède
des bases à travers le monde dont une à
djibouti que vous avez dirigé
est-ce que c'est d'abord important
d'être présent pour la france sur le sol
africain et est ce que la france peut
aujourd'hui avec ses bases aériennes
intervenir très rapidement partout dans
le monde ses bases sa base aérienne
elles sont de toute façon et en premier
lieu le résultat de l'accord de défense
que l'on a avec ces pays à djibouti on a
un accord de défense par exemple la
france est responsable de la défense
aérienne du territoire de djibouti donc
il faut bien mettre un radar des avions
pour intercepter un éventuel pénétrant
donc c'est pour dire que ses bases
aériennes en a bien sûr en afrique on a
aujourd'hui vous savez en jordanie pour
l'irak syrie on à djibouti et puis on a
sur nos territoires et départements
d'outre-mer mais c'est ce grand principe
que l'on annonce régulièrement c'est que
quand il ya une allumette qui s'allument
quelque part dans le monde
il vaut mieux l'éteindre plutôt
qu'attendre et que ce soit je devienne
un feu et on va intervenir rapidement à
travers ces éléments détachés mais que
ce soit bien sûr les régiments de
l'armée terre les hélicoptères les
avions de chasse où les avions de
transport on est capable d'intervenir et
notamment par exemple les catastrophes
naturelles
dès qu haïti vous savez les pauvres sont
souvent ils font souvent face à des
catastrophes naturelles
eh bien on interviendra très rapidement
parce que parce que bien nous avons des
territoires ou des avions des tâches est
pas loin
donc c'est pour dire combien ce
déploiement dans le monde est assez
important par exemple l'asie du sud est
ces pays-là d'onésime alesi vietnam eh
bien il faut savoir dans cette région
n'a 7000 militaires français présents en
permanence donc cette présence là elle a
plusieurs évidemment pour conséquence
sur le rayonnement la présence
l'influent ch
et puis les affaires du monde la gestion
des affaires du monde avec cette place
au conseil de sécurité et ce droit de
veto
la france a naturellement cette aptitude
à se tourner vers les affaires du monde
et ses bases détachés dans lequel nous
avons des capacités
les militaires en font évidemment partie
je le disais tout à l'heure vous avez
justement diriger un sept bases
aériennes à djibouti vous êtes aussi à
général de corps aérien si si je ne me
trompe pas c'est un poste un des postes
les plus haut placés dans la hiérarchie
militaire
quelles sont les qualités tout
simplement indispensable pour être un
bon général
voilà voilà une bonne question
alors ça c'est cet intéressant les
bonnes qualités pour être un général je
pense que alors évidemment l'institution
à travers votre formation et votre
montage enfin vos grades vous choisi en
fonction des qualités mais pour moi
qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre d'un vrai
général la première chose c'est il faut
qu'il soit un leader c'est qu'un leader
de quelqu'un qui a ce leadership en lui
avec l'éthique qui va avec et où on le
reconnaît à travers sa posture son
intention son attention aux autres
intentions et attention aux autres et il
a le côté qui est à la fois humain et à
la fois le côté aussi qui est militaire
c'est à dire qu'il est là entre
guillemets c'est le seul de l'état qui a
le droit tué entre guillemets une fois
que le président a décidé d'engager
d'engager une force dans une opération
le militaire à cette qu'elle soit
terriens aviateurs marin forces
spéciales et tous et gendarmes aussi
bien sur cette aptitude à cette aptitude
ce droit a tué donc il faut savoir
prendre du recul et est le chef le bon
chef c'est celui qui est capable de
prendre du recul sur les événements et
c'est pour ça que je dis souvent qu'un
bon chef est entouré de bons adjoints
verts qu'il leur fait confiance et à
travers la subsidiarité
il leur délègue de responsabilité dont
il a la charge
mais il est bien entouré et il est
capable de prendre un peu de recul
ça c'est quelque chose à mon avis qui
est important donc ses qualités humaines
ses qualités évidemment de meneur
d'hommes et puis ses qualités ce sera
des gic d'être capable de prendre mieux
du recul mais surtout surtout pour nous
français être capable de défendre
vis-à-vis du politique qui emploie
l'armée les armées en général qui est
capable de démontrer ce que l'armée
capable de leur apporter dans leur
politique globale à travers une approche
globale
l'action militaire n'est qu'une action
parmi une approche globale bien sûr et
on l'a vu dans tout les pays tous les
crises si vous ne pensez pas à la
justice l'économie à l'éducation à
reconstruire les forces armées la police
et la sécurité
ses fonctions régaliennes qu'on en dit
de l'état le chef militaire s'intègre
dans cette approche globale mais il
n'est pas le seul général charef vous
parliez tout à l'heure de leadership
il vous en a fallu très certainement
quand vous étiez en charge de la
composante aérienne air de la dissuasion
nucléaire
qu'est ce que ça représente sa com comme
ben responsabilité c'est un poste très
particulier parce que vous savez nous en
france dans cette division nous avons
deux composantes la composante
océaniques avec quatre sous marins
nucléaires dont un est quelque part on
sait pas très bien où et les deux
escadrons de milliers de rafale qui
apporte le missile nucléaire
cette mission elle est très importante
et je note que depuis 1964
la première prise d' alerte par l'armée
de l'air nucléaire avec son mirage iv et
son et son boeing ravitailleurs c'est
une permanence et avec un contrat
opérationnel et les face à travers toute
cette action de préparer être prêt au
cas où cette crédibilité technique et
opérationnelle elle doit être montrée
vers les plus hautes instances bien sûr
pour montrer que cette composante est
capable de faire à tout moment quelque
chose mais aussi vis-à-vis du monde
c'est de la crédibilité politique
encore une fois comme je le disais et la
crédibilité opérationnel les gens qui
mettent en oeuvre cette capacité
militaire très technologique ils sont
opérationnels et ils savent faire et ça
c'est un moyen fort dans dans la
crédible
tu es que l'on donne de notre dissuasion
nucléaire la crédibilité bien c'est sur
ces paroles qu'on va se quitter général
charest merci d'avoir été avec nous
aujourd'hui mon général et merci
également à vous de nous avoir suivis
dans ce nouveau numéro du débris du dock
une émission un documentaire je le
rappelle mitsouko et les secrets des
avions de combat russes elles sont pas
retrouvés dès maintenant sur notre site
air france point tv à très bientôt vous
et à très vite pour un nouveau numéro du
débrief du doc
[Musique]